Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and I'm here in the garage of Team Edge with Team Edge
Say "Hi", Team Edge
J-Fred: We're Team Edge
Matt: This isn't my garage
J-Fred: I'm not Markiplier
J-Fred: Yes, it is
Matt: It's- it's a studio space that we bought
[Mark coughing in the background]
J-Fred: We paid millions of dollars for it
Mark: Sorry
(Matt Giggling)
Mark: They were rich, they're now poor, 'cause they spent all the money on this amazing, elaborate set
Bryan: Ooooooh [x6]
Mark: Anyway,
(Matthias Laughs)
Mark: Should I not mention that?
Matthias: No, I was just messing with you
Mark: Oh, okay, cool
Mark: So, we have this shock collar here, and we're gonna be playing 'Who Wants To Be A Millionare' [Kinky]
And while we wear it,
(laughing) We have the option of skipping?
I don't know, we haven't decided the rules. They made it up... I just came here...
J-Fred: We have- we have 3 skips
If you wanna skip, you get shocked
You can only skip three times
Whoever goes the longest makes the most money
We're not actually playing for money but
[someone trap remix this part]
Whoever gets the furthest, wins the game
Mark: I'm just gonna cut like words from each of our sentences
Matt: We are - getting shocked - in this - challenge
Bryan: Alright....
J-Fred: See?
[Bryan gets shocked]
Mark: Yeah, it's like every once in a while!
Bryan: I felt it in my nuts!
[Laughter & Whahahat's!?]
Mark: Why is your hand so connected to your nuts?
Bryan: Woah!
*Giggles*
Bryan: That was a trip!
J-Fred: If you don't get these first few questions, I get to slap you too, 'cause you are an idiot if you don't get them
Mark: There's a lot of rules being made up on the fly here
J-Fred: That's how Team Edge works.
Bryan: You just push that button..
Woah woah, wait!
Wait!
Don't turn it on! No!
J-Fred: It didn't get you, I told you!
Bryan: No, 'cause he just turned it on, don't push it again!
Matt: I know, I know!
Bryan: I'm sweating!
J-Fred: That's what I'm saying, he reacts - he reacts even when you don't press it!
Bryan: 'Cause I thought it was going to shock me!
Matt: Hey, hey, calm down
Question-
Bryan: When you have a shock collar on your neck, you can't calm down! You can't!
Mark: This is probably safe, we don't know.
J-Fred: And a little kinky [That's what I said!]
[Ummm excuse me what? Please no. Wait what.]
J-Fred: What piece of advice most often follows: "If at first you don't succeed..."?
A) Try again
B) Throw in the towel
C) File an appeal
D) Give up?
Bryan: Try again?
J-Fred: Try again.
Mark: YAAAAAY (clapping)
Oh, is that right? (giggle) OK YAAAY
J-Fred: Wow, that's slow!
Matt: Turn on audio
J-Fred: Question number two:
Which planet does Superman come from?
A) Krypton    Bryan: Krypton
J-Fred: B... okay.  Mark: Chica, shut up!
*various giggles*
that's correct
Matt: She looked over at you like... Brian: Alright next.
J-Fred: Question number three
Which.......      Mark (sad voice): Oh look at her, she's like...
OH NOOOOOOO IT'S OKAY
IT'S OKAY...    J-Fred: shes wagging
Matt: wagging her tail
J-Fred: Question number three, Bryan
Bryan: Three... OHHH WHY'D YOU DO THAT!!!??? [Spazzing]
WHY?!??!
Matt: I did not shock you!
WHY!? YES IT DID!
Matt: Bull, it was off! Bryan: IT SHOCKED ME!
Matt: Bull!! Bryan: I felt it!
IT SHOCKED ME! Matt: Bull
J-Fred: You just lost a skip Matt: He just made that up
J-Fred: No, 'cause, I don't think he knew you pressed it
Mark: Yeah, I think you shocked him
Bryan: You shocked me, how else did I know you shocked...
Matt: IT WAS OFF!
This thing is, uh, defective
J-Fred: Maybe it turns off right when you *demon laughter*
Matt:  So he gets that one to go ahead then? He gets to skip it?
Bryan: Why do I skip?
J-Fred: Nah, I'm just kidding
J-Fred: You can skip it if you want, because he'd shocked you
Mark: But these are the easy ones
Bryan: Yeah, I don't want to use my skip on the easy one, go
J-Fred: Which drug was launched in the late 1990s as the cure for impotence?
Bryan: What? Say it again
A) Ibuprofen
Mark: You don't know this one?
B) Aspirin
C) Viagra
Bryan: Oh, okay. Viagra
J-Fred: Cetaphil. No, that's it.
J-Fred: Look how slow that is. It's the slowest game ever
Matt: That's correct
in case we didn't announce that
J-Fred: Okay, Bryan, you're up to.. you have the possibility
of getting.. What is that... fourty-five hundred dollars?
Oh, that's question number four: five hundred dollars (giggling)
Mark: Laughing
J-Fred: Question number four: Where does Napoleon Bonaparte originate from?
A) Romandy
B) Sardinia
C) Sicily
or D) Corsica
You can skip it if you want, if you
get this wrong,
your turn is over
Bryan: Uhh.. I'll skip it.
J-Fred: Okay, skip
Give him a..
Matt: SEE!!
J-Fred: No, press it dude!
Press it
PRESS IT!!
(GIGGLING)
Bryan: Maybe, that's not the butt— okay, okay, okay!
Okay, but that's not very hard of a shock
J-Fred: Okay, turn it up
J-Fred: In a bullfight, who kills the bull?
A) The butcher
B) A volunteer
C) The matador
Bryan: Matador
J-Fred: The public..the matador
Question number five for one thousand dollars, which chase piece
Whoa (giggles) Which CHESS piece
Mark: Nice
NIIICE
J-FRED: (giggles) always stays on the same color squares?
A) Knight
B) Queen
C) King
D) Bishop
Are you going to want to take a skip on
this one?
Mark: You know it, it's fine, you got it
Bryan: I don't play chess, I don't know
Mark: Bryan, it's okay
J-Fred: Okay, so skip
Wait, are you gonna skip it?
Matt: He can hear when I'm pressing it...
Bryan: The knight
Matt: Oh, come on dog, that wasn't right! Mark: Ohhh...
J-Fred: WRONG!!
Matt: It's the bishop
J-Fred: You Lose
J-Fred: Why would you do that?
Bryan: I thought it was the knight!
Matt: The knight does an L, dog!
Mark: It's the bishop
Bryan: I DON'T PLAY CHESS!
Mark: WOOOOOOWWW
Bryan: So, I'm done right? What'd I end up at, five hundred bucks?
Matt: A thousand
Bryan: A thousand bucks
Matt: Oh, no
J-Fred: No, five hundred, because you didn't get it right
Matt: OHH BUUUHUUU
J-Fred: Wow, that's uhh.. shameful
Bryan: Look at Chica, she's just like.. spread eagle
Mark: Yeah, Chica does that
J-Fred: That's like the funniest thing I've ever seen
Mark: She's adorable
J-Fred: I say it's the funniest thing, but I'm
not laughing that hard
Matt: That's the funniest thing I've ever seen
Mark: This is the funniest video
*awkward silence*
Mark: *cough*
J-Fred: Okay, Mark
Mark: I can't talk
J-Fred: If you don't get this question, I get to punch you in the face
Mark: Okay
J-Fred: On what date is American Independence Day?
A) 25th of December
On the same day as Christmas
Mark: July 4th, c'mon, give me an easy one!
J-Fred: 4th of July, look at how slow this is
Matt: Aannndd theeeeerreee!
Mark: I need a little more space, Jesus Christ
There we go, okay
J-Fred: Okay, this is (giggling)
Mark: Just choking on it ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
J-Fred: Uh, how many sides does an isosceles triangle have, Mark?
Mark (giggling): An isosceles triangle?!
How many sides does this specific type of triangle,
how many sides does this triangle have? (giggling)
J-Fred: Okay, three!
Mark: Three, yes
Matt (laughing): He just didn't answer.
WRONG!!
Mark: We all know
J-Fred: Three for three hundred dollars
According to the popular phrase, "don't bite the hand that," what?
Mark: Feeds
J-Fred: Feeds you
(Mark laughing adorably)
Matt: Seems like his are real easy
J-Fred: 'Kay, question number four for five hundred dollars
The ability to see outside your central area of focus is called what?
Mark: Peripheral vision
J-Fred: Oh... very nice.
J-Fred: I haven't even had to read him any of the things, I even answered one myself for him
(Markimoo laughing)
Matt: How is... How is he manipulating this so far?
Bryan: He's cheating the system
J-Fred: Oooh, this one might be interesting! Matt: He must be a genius
J-Fred: You either know this or you don't, just like every other questions
(Markipooper laughing) Right!
J-Fred: How was Macaulay Culkin left at home in 1990?
Mark: Uhh, his parents go on a vacation without him
J-Fred: A) Alone (laughing)
Mark: Wait, whaaaaattt?! (giggling)
J-Fred: B) Hungry
C) Grounded
D) Injured
ALONE!!
I'm gonna answer it for him! Matt: NO!!
(sad) Yeah...
J-Fred: What?
Mark: Wait, what was the question again?
J-Fred: How was he left home?
Mark: How was he left home?!?!
J-Fred: He would've got.. I guess
Matt: No, he wouldn't have!
Mark: I would have gotten it!
I'm not..I'm not (mumbled) Bryan here
J-Fred: Question number six for two thousand dollars,
a car with the international registration letter E comes from where?
A) England
B) Switzerland
C) Spain
D) Ireland
Mark: I would guess England
J-Fred: You wanna skip it or guess?
Mark: No.. uhh... if it's got the designation *E*..
J-Fred: Final answer?
Mark: Wait, hang on, what were the other options?
Matt: Wait, how would a fifth grader know this?
J-Fred: England, Switzer-.. It's not Fifth Grader!
Mark: Yeah, it's not Fifth Grader
J-Fred: How long have you been here...where have you been?
Matt: I thought we were playing "How To Be A Fifth Grader"
Matt and Bryan: Wait, what?
Mark: I don't know, what are you talking about?
Matt: "How To Win A Fifth Grader", no
J-Fred: Yes. (realization) WHAT!?!?!?
Bryan: "Are You Smarter Than A Fifth Grader?"
Matt: "Are You Smarter Than A Millionaire?"
J-Fred: Okay, just to clarify, there are no fifth graders being won at the end of this game
Mark: Whaaatttt? Bryan: What?
J-Fred (pointing at matthias): That's what you said, "How To Win A Fifth Grader"
Mark: Whoaaa! (GIGGLING)
J-Fred: Okay
Matt: K-no
J-Fred: Final answer, England, Switzerland, Spain, or Ireland?
Mark: I would think England
J-Fred: Okay, final answer?
Mark: Yeeaahhh!
Matt: It was wrong
Mark: WHAT!?!?!?!?!?!?!
What was it?
AAAAAAAAAAHHHHHH (Mark gets shocked)
WHAT JUST HAPPENED?!?!
Matt: Was I not supposed to shock him?
J-Fred (laughing): No!
Mark: What was it? What was it? (Spain, genius...)
J-Fred: I don't know, it never told me!
Matt: He- you pointed it at the camera, they didn't see
Mark: Yeah!
Is that how that-how this game works?
Mark: OWWWW!
Matt: Uh, this thing doesn't work!
I just turned it on
Mark: OWWW
Matt: Did that really hurt?
Mark: Yeah.. that's a good level, that's a- no, no, turn it back, it's a good level
Matt: BLAH BLAH BLAH BLAH
Mark. BLAH BLAH BLAH, let's shock this guy (points at Matt)
Bryan: I just wanna point this, this out, he turned it down to three, it was at five
Matt: I DID NOT!!
Bryan: I CAUGHT HIM, I CAUGHT HIM!!
I was like, "Waiiit a second here..."
BRBAJBTFLA
J-Fred: How did we both know to do that at the same exact time
(Continuous laughter)
Matt: I didn't do it on purpose
Bryan: I didn't touch it, I was just joking
Matt: Okay, I wasn't messing with you guys, I legitimately thought it wasn't on!
J-Fred: Okay, don't cry, it's okay
Matt (super crybaby mode): It wasn't ON!
J-Fred: Ohh... I hate my brother
Matt: Stop!
Can't you just do it right the first time?
Bryan: Why did you have to mess with it, trying to be funny man and make it all limp
J-Fred: Trying to be funny man
Trying to be funny man
Matt (Jamaican voice): Trying to be funny man, huh?
Bryan: Huh?
Matt: Uh!
Bryan: Funny man over h— 'kay, there.
J-Fred: 'Kay, restart
Matt: NO, I DON'T TRUST YOU!!
I DON'T TRUST YOU!!
Mark: It's fine
Matt: I will shock myself
Mark: It's fine, aww, c'mon
We'll shock him together
Matt: I don't trust you
J-Fred: Okay
This question is probably the dumbest question I ever read in my life
Matt (impatiently): Then just read it...
Bryan: Why is it taking so long dude?
Mark: yeah
J-Fred: What would you do with a burrito?
A) Wear it
B) Eat it
C) Play it
D) Drive it
WHAT?!?
I think you want to.. I think you want to wear the burrito
Mark: It's like an episode of Sponge Bob Matt: I will punch you in the face
Bryan: DO IT!! I DARE YOU
I will throw you across this garage
Matt (mockingly): Mmmkay
J-Fred: I think you wanna wear the burrito
Matt: Let me put it in my mouth ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
J-Fred: Skip
Matt: That's what you do with burritos
Matt (singing): You put it in my mouth
Mark: If I press the up and down, it doesn't shock, right?
J-Fred: Turns out he's correct
Question number two for two hundred dollars
J-Fred: How many milligrams.. how many milligrams in a gram? (1000)
A) 1000
these are a lot harder...
Matt: Yeah, what?
Mark: That's easy! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
J-Fred: That's super easy for me!
Matt: I'm American!
Mark: You still should know this Bryan: Good for you!
J-Fred: I was a science major and you (Mark) were an engineering major, so we should know this
He (bryan) should probably know it too
Matt: I was a film major, dude!
Mark: Then you know this, right?
Matt: Oh yeah, (deep voice) how many grams is your camera, (normal voice) oh, I don't know, bro!
Mark and Bryan: What?
Matt: Exactly!
J-Fred: Exactly
Bryan: Answer the question!
J-Fred: How many milligrams in a gram?
A) 1000
B) 100
C) 500 Bryan: This is easy
J-Fred: D) 10
Matt: 10
Bryan: NOOO!!!
Mark: WOOOWWW
Bryan: *Milli*gram
Shock him!
Matt: Don't, no, that's not a shock!
Bryan: Yes, you shocked him when you got it wrong Matt: That's not a shock
That's not a shock
No, it's a skip!
ARRGHH
J-Fred: It didn't get you, did it?
Matt: Yes, it did
Bryan: No, it didn't
Mark: Did it?
J-Fred: Milli..
Matt: NO, AAAHHH, STAHP!
I DON'T TRUST YOU!!
Mark: Why not? J-Fred: Milli- is three
J-Fred: You're done, you lost
Mark: Yeah
Bryan: That's your turn Mark: Wow!
Matt: What was it?
Mark and J-Fred: It was a thousand
Matt: There are thousand...
Bryan: Milli-, milli- is a thousand
Mark: Mill, the Latin root of, I think it's thousand, I'm not sure, yeah
Bryan: Millisecond
Matt: No, this is rigged
J-Fred: Times three, it's times three
Matt: This is rigged
Bryan: How much, you got one question right?
Matt: Oh, how was— Mark (laughing): Yeah, he got one question right!
Matt: How was he home alone? ALONE !?!
(Mark's awesome laugh)
WHAT?
Mark: Well, that's equivalent to your dumb answer
Matt: Which of the following is not gas?
A) Nitrogen
B) Mercury
J-Fred: Mercury
Mark: Nice
Mark: Nice man
J-Fred: That's a, that's...
Mark: That was the first question?
J-Fred: That's a pretty easy question, but it's not as like..
Mark: Not a burrito
J-Fred: It's not: "What do you do with a burrito?"
Mark: WHAT DO I DO WITH THIS!?!
AHHHHHH
Bryan: Put it on my head
J-Fred: I think I need to drive this
Matt: 'Kay, from what language does the word alphabet come from?
A) Latin
B) Sanskrit
C)Greek
or D) French
J-Fred: Oh, that is question number two?
Matt: That's what I'm saying, he got the easy ones!
J-Fred: Latin
Matt: NO, GREEK, IT'S GREEK
Bryan: What are you doing, what are you doing?
J-Fred: I lost
Bryan: No, well, put it back on! J-Fred: WHAT?
J-Fred: No, that's not part of the game! Bryan: Put it back on!
Bryan: Put it back on!
Matt: Go, go, go, go! J-Fred: OW! OW! OWWW!
J-Fred: That's not a part of the game
Mark: Wow!
I won with a thousand?
J-Fred: What the crap, okay, first of all, that was a hard question
Mark: I didn't know that either. Latin or Greek, like, one would think that Latin is the root of all of it but
Matt: Alpha though, alpha should have given it away Mark: That's true,
The Greek alphabet...
OH, GREEK ALPHABET
OHHHH
Bryan: So you guys, we have to determine who's last place
J-Fred: Wait, what was your first three questions
Bryan: It doesn't matter, let's move on to you're the losers (grammar much?)
J-Fred: What do you do with your nose?
Taste
Smell
Hear
Bryan: Loser either has to spin the wheel, or get shocked at the highest level.
Mark: What's the wheel?
J-Fred: Oh, this is the wheel of punishments
Matt: Wheel of misfortune
J-Fred: Wheel of misfortune, correct
Mark: That's a good question to ask them Bryan: Okay, alright!
the loser not only has to get shocked, but then they have to spin the wheel Matt: No, no, no,
Matt: One or the other
Bryan: C'mooooon!
Alright, alright, so whoever answers it first, right?
Is that what we're doing?
Mark: Yeah, sure
Bryan: 'Kay, Reprise Records was set up by which singer after he stopped recording with Capital?
Bon Jovi
Kurt Cobain
Frank Sinatra
Bruce Sprinting [sic]
(everyone laughs)
Mark: Bruce Sprinting
Bryan: Kurt Cobain
J-Fred: Kurt Cobain, I say!
Matt: No, it's not Kurt-
I just say it's not
Bryan: No, what's your answer?
Matt: I say it's not Kurt Cobain
Bruce Sprinting (Bruce Springsteen)
bryan: Alright, it is...
Frank Sinatra, you guys both lose!
Mark: You both suck
Not that I would've known that but you guys suck
Bryan: Okay, I'm gonna need to do that again 'cause it's making me restart
ROCK PAPER SCISSORS!
How about that?
Rock Paper Scissors!
Rock Papers Scissors!
Mark: Oh, Jesus...
Bryan: This is the worst thing ever Mark: Oh my God!
Bryan: You have no idea how painful it is to watch them play Rock Paper Scissors, 'cause they do the same thing
Bryan: 'Kay
Mark: Jesus
Bryan: C'mon! Try and win!
J-Fred: I win!!
Bryan: Spin the wheel!
J-Fred:  Paper
Matt: No, this is fire
Bryan: Go, spin it, spin the wheel!
J-Fred: Water balloon firing squad!  Matt: OH, C'MON!!
Mark: Hey, I like that!
That sounds good
Matt: Water balloon firing squad
J-Fred: This is Matthias' first time doing that, by the way
Alright, off to the back yard to throw fifty water balloons at Matthias
Mark: We're gonna throw water balloons
Bryan: You gotta wear this though
Mark: I'm not gonna wear this J-Fred: Mark is gonna get shocked real quick
Oh, 'cause we promised at the beginning
Bryan: We did, you can't break a promise Mark: Yeah, alright
Alright, hang on...
ARRRGGGHH!!!
Bryan: I didn't even do it yet!
Mark: What button did you press?
Bryan: Plus two!
Mark: OH MY GOD!
(voice cracks) AHHHH!!!
Bryan: His arm got stuck: "AHHHHHH!!!"
Mark: AHHHHH!
Why don't you try that?
The plus two is like, to an extreme
I think that just means doubling it
OH MY GOD
Bryan: Put your fingers on it, put your fingers on it
Mark: NO!!!
Bryan: Just put your fingers on it
Mark: NO, you put your fingers on it!
J-Fred: Apparently, Mark doesn't know math, 'cause plus two is not doubling it, it's adding two
Mark: No, it felt like it was doubling, 'cause we were on five and it went up to eight, and that was more
Bryan: OH SHOOT!!!
Mark: That was on my neck!
Mark: So we're just going, right now?
Bryan: Yeah! J-Fred: Yes!
Mark: We're not gonna like, warm him up
Bryan: This is his punishment for landing on it
*screaming*
Matt: I was trying—
*more screaming*
Matt: Whoa, I'm falling into the— OHHHH
*EVEN MORE SCREAMING ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)*
Oww, my side dude!
*SCREAMING TO THE MAX*
Bryan: Alright Mark, one more each, here
Matt: Oh my gosh, this isn't over?!
*shouting*
Mark: Alright, we're done here
Matthias, how do you feel?
Matt: Owww, welts dude..
Mark: Oh wow, that is a welt
So anyway, thank you so much for watching, uhh
if you wanna see another challenge that we did, we're gonna be doing the Backwards Action Challenge
I don't even know how that one goes, we didn't even know how this one was gonna go, so,
let us know if you enjoyed it and thanks again everybody for watching
J-Fred: You wanna go see that video, it's in the link down in the description below on our channel
Bryan and Matt: Oooh
J-Fred: He said bye!
Mark: I was about to do my outro, the thing that I always do at the end of every video
J-Fred: I thought he was done
Mark: Don't touch me,
Matt: He gets to be shocked Mark: with your sweet tender kisses ;)
Mark: He also pussied—
J-Fred: At least not during the video
Mark: He pussied out of the neck eight so.. what is this guy?
Anyways yeah, links are in the description, thanks again for watching
As always, I'll see in you in the next one
Mark: Buh bye! Team Edge: Peace!